[Music]
we're all familiar with this next story
picture any movie in which a hero or
heroine is running from a bad guy
they dunk into a room and try and
barricade the door shut by using the
furniture they find and this is our
story
is it actually feasible to barricade and
make a room impenetrable with the
furniture you find in that room this is
such a classic and perfect Mythbusters
myth a standard movie trope being put to
a rigorous set of tests I cannot wait
your 45-second star and three two one is
it possible to barricade a door using
furniture
it's a classic Hollywood scene but is it
really fiction this Mythbusters movie
marathon is drawing to a close and how
it ends is up to the beasts of the bay
big Tommy takes his cue
and at the end of the day tommy's force
is too great for both the door and the
furniture stack somebody order pizza
that was awesome
Tommy you are the best you broke the
door oh this song delivered pieces
amazing absolutely stunning could've
been better oh my gosh yep the action
made for a great scene but with so many
variables at play is an alternate
successful ending possible big Tommy was
amazing for this experiment I mean just
perfect but it's clear that Jesse and
Rachael's strategy which you see in
movies all the time was totally
unsuccessful so if Valerie and I are
gonna succeed we're gonna have to come
up with something totally different can
barely wait so the teams switch roles
and prep for the second set of
alternative variables I brought a plan
all right so here's the scenario you are
the country's number two bounty hunter
beyond the store is the FBI's most
wanted you get beyond this door you'll
be number one hmm these doors don't
stand a chance against the big Tommy
Burns that's what I'm talking about
let's get it Adam and Valerie have their
work cut out
Rachel and Jesse have prepped the
bedroom with carpet floor and a new door
for added intruder protection Tommy's
gonna have to get through the solid core
interior door next all right that uh
cute 8/2 ballerina Adam are you ready
ready
all right furniture barricade you're 45
seconds start now right this way hold on
hold on
actually Adam and Valerie strategically
placed the shelf okay yep the single bed
a chair and bedside all end-to-end to
try and jam the gap between the opposing
wall and the door and leaving no stone
unturned they add the dresser for
additional weight there we go here we go
what's up right up against there that's
it done Q big Tommy
the barricade makes an impressive start
at keeping the beast at bay the door is
smashed into smithereens
while the furniture holds strong but the
payoff is inevitable wow I am seriously
totally winded that actually worked for
most of the time that was terrifying
that door is annihilated completely gone
there's no doubt about the Hollywood
drama but what about the myth all right
guys it is time to call this myth and
I'm gonna point out big Tommy did make
it through the door on both tests yes he
did but you and Valerie's technique of
bracing from the door to the opposite
wall was actually really effective and
it almost worked
and clearly it depends on the door the
furniture and the size of the room so
what I'm hearing is this myth is
plausible plausible I think it's
plausible
yes plausible you're a champion yep this
one's not just for the silver screen
given the right circumstances and some
quick thinking our furniture barricade
just might lead to a happy ending
you
[Music]